nicolas hulot vous côtoyer les gorilles
vous vous dorer au soleil avec les lions
de mer vous plongez avec les otaries et
je me demande si vous n'avez pas
chevaucher les baleines alors vous vous
plaisez à la fréquentation des espaces
déserté je me suis posé cette question
aimez-vous encore les hommes fait je
pense que le regard qu'ont apporté entre
autres pendant ces huit années sur la
planète qu'espèce d'hymne à la nature en
fête et un inventaire des phares les
plus éclatants de la beauté du monde et
qu'ils sont nombreux a élargi notre
vision du monde nous en a donné
peut-être une vue un peu plus complète
un peu plus juste nous a pas pour autant
éloigné je pense des hommes je pense
qu'elle nous en a rapproché avec
peut-être plus de discernement plus de
nuances qu'on l'avait auparavant je
pense vous êtes plus près des animaux
que des hommes c'est ce que je crois
voir dans sofia d'abord on dit booth
moyens aux houches royal il ya deux
sonorités en fait à l'origine c'était
une petite ville indienne en terre de
feu et laisser un nom indien de donc là
les indiens prononce le hqe ushuaïa il
le chante plus qu'il ne le prononce
d'ailleurs c'est vrai qu'on
s'intéressait plus aux grands sites
naturels aux belles expressions de
nature et aux communautés humaines mais
celle qui était un peu à l'écart du
temps parce que je pour tous pour une
bonne raison c'est qu'on peut pas courir
tous les registres
on n'est pas un magazine d'actualités et
d'informations je crois qu'on a pris le
parti pris du rêve le rêve est donc lié
à une certaine beauté
on n'a jamais triché mais quelquefois on
a oublié de tourner la caméra dans les
directions les choses étaient plus laide
donc on s'est contenté de ces petites
communautés qui brillait encore de
beauté magnifique et dans votre espace
tout à fait personnelle nicolas hulot
vous avez l'air l'eau le feu des
éléments qui sont naturelles mais que
peut-être vous n'aviez pas approché
avant que de vous consacrer à cette
émission
contrairement à ce que les deux temps en
temps les gens pensent
notre expérience et notre état d'esprit
procède pas d'une volonté pratiquer un
certain nombre de disciplines sportives
ou aventurière qui sont des mots que je
me potro parce qu'ils correspondent pas
tellement à notre mentalité je crois que
c'est une quête de connaissance de
perception parce que je donne souvent
cet exemple est parce que je crois qu'il
nous correspond tout à fait quand on
vole par exemple et c'est vrai que ça
fait partie d'une entité de l'émission
parce qu'on a souvent le regard des
oiseaux pour une bonne raison c'est
qu'ils subliment tous les choses vues du
ciel sont très belles
on aime voler on aime voler pas parce
qu'être là haut ça nous différencie
ousseynou quantifie par rapport à ceux
qui sont au sol et parce que d'abord je
pense que ça fait partie de notre vraie
nature
et puis quand on vole c'est une
connaissance une connaissance de quoi
dans un environnement qui est le nôtre
d'une matière qui s'appelle lr
aujourd'hui quand je parle de l'air j'en
ai peut-être pas une connaissance
chimiques comme lavoisier quoique mais
j'en ai une perception sensorielle
intuitive et sensitive jeu les palper
cet air quand je parle de l'eau de la
mer c'est une matière qui représente
quelque chose donc je crois que on a
agrandi la perception du monde dans
lequel on vit c'est juste encore une
fois un élargissement de la vision du
monde
c'est quelqu'un allait cette très belle
phrase le savoir ne devient connaissance
qu'à travers le filtre de l'expérience
dont je pense que j'ajoute l'expérience
un certain savoie mais lorsqu'on regarde
tout ce que vous faites
on a l'impression qu'un journée vous
retirer vous allez je ne sais pas sur
quelle mont athos
vous irez vous installer comme si mais
ce qu'une impression tout à fait
personnelle comme si aujourd'hui même si
vous êtes heureux de vous promener
partout comme si vous en aviez assez et
je crois que c'est votre dernière année
alors il n'y a aucune lassitude non bien
entendu notre avenir s'il y en a un qui
doit être ni blasé ni la ccl bien moins
que je pense que les gens ont conscience
et justes et moi aussi qu'on ait des
sacrés chanceux et quand on sait la
sensibilité plus on la confronte plus
elle est réceptive et plus le seuil de
respectives it et s'élargit donc au
contraire je m'émerveille à des shows
auxquels m'émerveiller payet en revanche
pensent qu'il ya un temps pour tout dans
la vie il ya un temps pour l'action et
un temps pour la réflexion je crois
qu'au niveau de l'action je suis sevré
alors un mot de au katanga sûr
de vous regarder par l'otc gandhi c'est
un personnage qui vous intéressent qui
fait peut-être les choses d'une manière
différente
etes-vous d'abord sur sur le même
créneau bon je ne vais pas regarder est
venu en photo si je veux être un peu
cynique et rex pour moi c'est un triste
clown
pourquoi je veux pas être méchant mais
je te dis que ça ne sert à moi j'estime
que c'est un bon il va être non je vais
vous dire pourquoi je trouve toujours
dommage quand il ya un déficit
d'imagination que ce soit sur notre
chaîne ou sur les autres chaînes et
quand les racines de l'inspiration vont
s'ouvrir dans les corbeilles des chaînes
concurrentes
voilà c'est tout ce que j'ai dit 300
émissions c'est le bilan douche ou
ailleurs ça sera le on fera la 300e dans
l'année à 3 centièmes dans les prochains
voyages
là je pars au niger sur un site
archéologique super c'est un gisement de
dinosaures en plein désert pas très loin
d'agadès et après j'enchaîne nouvelle
zélande et nouvelle khalid vous soyez un
sens ça se traduit de quelle manière
vous soyez à c'est d'abord une
consonance avant d'avoir un sens mais
c'est un nom indien yagan malik est une
tribu d'indiens qui est malheureusement
disparu depuis en terre de feu et ça
veut dire c'est le nom de la ville la
plus fine du monde ça veut dire ça veut
dire la petite baie tournés vers l'ouest
tour lego vers l'ouest autres là-bas
l'ouest en général c'est là que le
soleil flamboie que l'horizon proclame
la beauté du monde comme l'a écrit
quelqu'un et puis c'est la conquête
voilà merci d'école merci
[Musique]